cette pièce l'association dax tedj la
travaille depuis janvier ils sont 28
danseurs chanteurs et musiciens a créé
leur comédie musicale c'est pas
seulement de jouer mais c'est aussi de
penser les arrangements donc on écoute
des chansons qui sont pas du tout écrite
pour notre formation pour nos
instruments et nous on doit tout à
écouter trotoux retranscrire nous mêmes
et c'est ça qui est vraiment difficile
qui prend beaucoup de temps mais qui est
aussi très intéressant dans notre
travail
une création artistique et solidaire en
mai elle sera jouée devant des enfants
atteints de cancer et de handicap qu'on
est venu avec l'idée de créer un
partenariat avec deux associations
d'achat c'est donc rêve d'enfance et
cherop qui soutiennent la cause
d'enfants atteints par le cancer et
souhaite représentation là sera suivie
d'ateliers de musique de danse et de
chant le jour suivant sur le campus donc
avec l'idée de bas de leur transmettre
notre passion pour promouvoir ce projet
les étudiants participent au concours
tous en scène dans une vidéo ils ont
expliqué leurs objectifs le prix ce
serait en fait ce serait pour justement
ne pas ne pas leur faire payer les
places parce que enfin si ça fait partie
du projet et voilà de devoir ouvrir des
balcons au comédia quitté être splendide
bah ça nous coûte aussi et le prix nous
permettrait justement de pouvoir
rembourser ses couleurs se serait réuni
une chance formidable de pouvoir mener
ce projet comme on veut et pouvoir
offrir à ses enfants ce qu'on voudrait
la pièce parle d'un jeune homme aux
goudes aventure une épopée sur le destin
arrivera-t-elle à transporter le jury
des réponses à la cérémonie de remise
des prix le 30 mars